بعد اعترافه بطاعات المخدرات نصف
الامريكيين يرغبون بمراجعه اقامه الامير
هاري فبحسب استطلاع جديد او ردته مجلات
فان اربعه وخمسين من البالغين في الولايات
المتحده 54 بالمئه طبعا من اصل 1500 ناخب
موسى الجليل يعتقدون انه يجب مراجعه
تاشيره الامير البريطاني بعدما اعترف
بطاعات الكوكايين والمخدرات في كتابه
اسبير تاتي النتيجه في الوقت الذي تضغط
فيه مؤسسه
ظهرتجفاونديشن المحافظه للافصاع عن طلب
التاشيره الخاص بالامير وكشفها للعلن
لمعرفه ما اذا كان قد ابلغ مسؤوليه الهجره
عن تاريخه مع المخدرات حيث يطلب من
المتقدمين لدخول ولايات المتحده الكشف عن
اي انتهاكات شخصيه للقوانين المتعلقه
بحيازه او استخدام او توزيع عقاقير غير
مشروعه وتؤدي طبعا لرفض المتقدم وعلى
الرغم من ان غالبيه الامريكيين يعتقدون
انه يجب مراجعه تاشيره الامير هاري قال
51% انهم شعروا ان الامير كان على حق في
الافصاح عن تاريخه مع تعاطي المخدرات في
مذكرات لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات